both Fuqua and Washington have stated
that the equalizer 3 ends the trilogy
and that this will likely be the last
time these two work in this franchise in
an exclusive interview with Looper Fuqua
mentioned how sad it was to be leaving
The Equalizer franchise behind well it's
like a breakup there was a moment where
I was sitting there watching it on the
big screen I thought
oh man I'm saying goodbye to Robert
McCall I don't want to do that but
everything comes to an end in an
interview with Empire Washington
expressed the same mixed feelings about
bidding farewell to McCall saying I
don't want to give it all away but he
meets someone lovely he's in a lovely
town and he seems to be at peace that
seems to be a good place to stop
obviously someone else can come and
direct a new entry or maybe a spin-off
focusing on Emma since it seems like her
story is just starting however that's
probably not happening at least for a
while so fans can expect this to be the
last time Robert McCall will be on the
big screen at least with Washington
playing him